greetings earthlings this is Questlove
knitted foodie former Captain Crunch
addict and I'm here to play who made
them
[Music]
first up we're gonna deal with the
office potluck that's when you bring a
dish to your workspace it's probably
best just to be considerate and stay in
the middle lane something very simple
probably the easiest thing that you can
bring to an office potluck a bag of ice
round one for our office potluck is oh
I'm in love with this the texture is
great this is enough pepper Rica assume
this is chives on top
either Zooey Deschanel or Khloe
Kardashian or Oprah made this I thought
that maybe Zooey was a vegetarian so I'm
kind of taking her out I'm not under
estimating the power of Chloe in the in
the kitchen but I'm gonna I'm gonna take
a hell Mary pass i'ma tell you i'ma pick
Oprah I don't think she has enough time
in the day I feel as though something
this simple was something that she
mastered long ago Oprah might be a
one-trick culinary pony and this might
be the one dish she knows out of master
in the case of friendsgiving if you're
going to play it safe
canned cranberry is the best thing about
the meal and especially the day after
Thanksgiving when you're making the
sammich mmm I see a sammich let's see
mac and cheese Wow
we either have that girl RiRi
Philadelphia's First Lady of culinary
finest Patti LaBelle or we have the
sexiest man alive 2019 John Legend okay
so there's a story on the internet about
how it took me 15 years to finally get a
meal out of Patti LaBelle she invited me
over for Thanksgiving and she threw down
when cooking mac and cheese there's a
certain level of Burnt that it has to be
Patti LaBelle's mac and cheese it's less
casserole and more like a hard square
and perfectly burnt with all types of
cheese in it seam is burnt texture here
lets me know that this authentically
came from a black chef I don't know
about Rihanna's power in the kitchen
John knows how to throw down in the
kitchen so this is 2019 sexiest mac and
cheese John Legend this is for the boozy
potluck oh okay
if you're like I am really not
knowledgeable on how to pair and match
your drinks I just filed a Cabernet I
kid you can't lose with it I feel like
this is an iced tea
sweet I know there's alcohol element in
here but threw me for a loop
I know Gabi goes hardcore she wouldn't
create something this this dainty jabs
out a lot of my interaction with George
Clooney was like my pre Fallon days I
don't know where you fall on the the
drinking scale of things I do know that
Martha can get turnt component Martha
Stewart Cheers it's the moment of truth
so let's go to round one off his pot
luck between Khloe Kardashian Oprah
Winfrey and Zooey Deschanel we had a
very tasty deviled egg yes I knew it I
knew that she had some culinary skills
but I figured that you know it was an
Arrested Development cause she's out
here saving the world
so yes option number two the
friendsgiving mac and cheese between bad
girl RiRi Patti LaBelle and John Legend
what hello
wow I'm shocked it was kind of hard to
judge who this truly was our final round
is sloshed giving the office booze party
our choices where George Clooney Martha
Stewart and Gabrielle Union in my book
mixtape potluck I commissioned Gabrielle
Union to make this fit so I don't even
have to look and of course it was
Gabrielle you gab I'm sorry I failed you
forgive me okay so that concludes
another who made that episode with the
quest level Edition I'm one in three
I hope I'm still in the food mafia I
still know a good dish when I taste it
Oprah you did well
Patti LaBelle maybe I'm gonna have to
come over to your house a few more times
Gabrielle do not pursue me and let me
remind you find people in closing we can
buy a mixtape potluck and stores
everywhere great gift great stocking
stuffer this is Questlove thank you very
much bad oh yes
[Music]